james is in evansville indiana hi james
how are you
hi dave pretty good good what's up
i have a college planning question
my wife and i have five young daughters
ages 10 to 13 months and
we have uh five 529
plans and are contributing the max for
the
tax incentive of 2500
we're now in a point in our life where
we could be applying more
but what does that look like for uh
having five kids
and hearing about eight years
having one go off to college yeah well
about five years
no no no eight years
yeah okay all right
um no it's more like women you've got
a 10 year old there it is ten years i'm
sorry i wrote i couldn't try and look at
these numbers i wrote it down i couldn't
find them
uh all right so
you know what what it amounts to is you
need to be putting in more
for the 10 year old than you do the 13
month old
because 13 month old's got a lot of time
to grow in that account
and so um who have you got your 529s
with
you got an advisor yes yes i haven't
we have an advisor we've got about 17
000
that it's grown in right now for that 10
year old no no
10 year old okay what i would do is sit
down with the advisor and make sure that
the money is invested in the 529 in good
growth stock mutual funds that have a
good track record
first if it is then i would ask them to
ask to tell you okay in order for the 18
the 10 year old in eight years to have x
number of dollars what have we got to
add to that account
in order for the next one to add you
know in so many years what have we got
to add to that account and it might end
up that you're putting
i'll just make up numbers you might end
up putting three thousand dollars
or four thousand dollars in the
10 year olds and you might end up
putting 500 in the
13 month old and they'll end up with the
same amount
okay because you got started later on
the 10 year old
yeah and so you didn't have as many
years for the money to grow
so uh it's um
it's kind of like life uh equal
is not fair
yeah they've already been told that yeah
equals not fair fair is not equal
and so uh you know if you've got a
special needs little brother little
sister we're gonna give more money and
make sure that that child is taken care
of
equal is not fair fair is not equal
is there fair is what you have at the
county
is there a magic sauce for
or about what should be put in uh
to be able to fully fund them uh
well what you need to do is just
determine what your goal is uh your goal
amount and you say okay
as an example they're going to go to
in-state schools they're in evansville
indiana they're going to go the
university of indiana
okay or indiana university all right and
you call them and go what's it cost to
go there
and what are your projections on your
tuition eight years from today and they
tell you it's gonna take a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to go there
with room and board four years eight
years from now
and uh for four years and i'm making up
numbers i don't know okay
today today tuition is about ten
thousand dollars plus room and board
per year for an in-state school average
nationally and so you're probably gonna
find somewhere around the ten thousand
dollar number
per year so that's for forty thousand
dollars plus if they're gonna stay in a
dorm and eat
okay so i'm gonna guess and say they can
go for a hundred grand eight years from
now
that's maybe 125 but you know you can
actually get the number from the
university
bother them a little bit or wherever you
think you want them to go to school and
then you can back into the actual goal
with your advisor they can put it into a
financial calculator and go okay in
order to do that
you need to save twenty six hundred and
forty two dollars a month or
twenty six hundred forty two dollars a
year they can tell you exactly what you
need to do
in order to get there once you have that
goal and you have the time period it's a
financial calculation at that point it's
a
math it's a math formula that goes into
a financial calculator and you can back
into it
so um but you need a target not just
so far your target has been we want to
save for college
it was very vague but if you really want
to do it perfectly and you want to know
when you're done this is how we did it
okay what we did was we said we wanted
i want a hundred thousand dollars per
kid and i
backed it out for a four-year-old and i
said in order to do that today i need
x in there and i just i had made some
money that year and i just put x in
there and then i was done
that account was over i never added to
it again never had to i put enough in
there that it was going to grow
for the four-year-old in 14 years to
this much so when daniel ramsey
got ready to go to school there was a
hundred thousand in there for him you
know and
it was ready to go and we just picked
out a number but uh you need to if you
want to
be really nerdy about it and i do
recommend that if you know what your
goal is you can back into your numbers
exactly
i've got a question about the
scholarship side of things because i
know with 529's like it's specifically
for school
if you save all this money and then your
kids are just get a ton of scholarships
what do they do with that money 100 of
what they get in scholarships can be
removed tax-free
know what now if they get if you've got
a hundred thousand dollars in then you
get 40 000 scholarships you can take 40
000
out and then you know oh really wow yeah
you just had to prove that you just have
to prove the scholarships if you're
audited
i didn't know that so you can remove it
and you've had tax-free growth on your
money in a 529 wow
that's cool that's wonderful so it
incentivizes the child to get
scholarships
and that type of thing and no they got
money free money totally okay
great yeah i mean they go buy a house
with it when they get out of college i
didn't realize that's
a pretty cool thing you're setting up
millionaire stuff here yeah setting your
kid up to be a millionaire before
they're 30.
because if they come out of school with
a hundred thousand bucks or 150 000
bucks and no student loan debt and they
go get a job making 70 or whatever
they're making these days right doing
whatever yeah
oh my gosh i mean you know 22 years old
you're making that and you got zero debt
and you already have a paid for house
ding ding yeah you're a millionaire by
the time you're 30. yeah and uh the
number i mean
it's just compound interest it's just
running the math out and so what he's
doing there the way he's planning
i mean he's thinking about it he got a
little baby 13 months and going this
baby's gonna go to college
but if once you dial all that in and
then you see what the
the next layer of effect of that is and
the next layer of that effect
yeah it gets rowdy right and when we
talk about you changed your family tree
you
really did change your family tree it's
real really